- All right, we are back,
and the bummer is the show's almost over.
I know you're sad.
But there is good news as well.
I have one more story to make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
So imagine you're
driving with your grandma
and she turns to you and says this.
- [Granddaughter] Just say it again.
- I said, I'm gonna blow your mind.
I want to get a tattoo.
- [Granddaughter] You
want to get a tattoo?
- Yeah, I thought something like that.
- [Granddaughter] Yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Granddaughter] Okay.
Well, we'll get you a tattoo.
- I'm gonna blow your mind.
I love her.
When 82-year-old Judy shared
her plan to get some ink,
her granddaughter could barely believe it,
so she recorded it to post on TikTok.
Just basically for proof.
I guess TikTokers
couldn't believe it either
because the video blew up,
but Judy stuck to her word
and not only did she get a tattoo,
it became a family affair
with seven other relatives
going under the tattoo gun.
It's a family affair, I love it.
We have Judy on the line right now
watching on WPTA at 3:00
PM in Fort Wayne, Indiana.
Hi Judy.
(audience cheers)
- Hi Kelly.
- Oh my gosh.
So I have to know what made
you want to get a tattoo at 82?
- Well, I read an article
in the Reader's Digest
about an 80-year-old lady
who gave herself a
tattoo for her birthday,
her 80th birthday.
I thought about that
and it just inspired me.
So I told my girls, I
want to get a tattoo.
- I love it.
I love it, it's so random.
So, what did you get and who
else in your family got them?
And by the way, great
face mask in that photo.
- Well, there was, like
I said, four generations.
Myself, my daughter, my
granddaughter and her wife,
my two great grandsons and their wives.
And my youngest grandson, Brendan.
He's 10 years old.
He couldn't get a tattoo.
(audience laughs)
We got a, what do you call that?
It's a musical clef.
- [Kelly] Okay, yeah.
- It's got a heart, a cancer ribbon,
and it's just in memory
of all of our loved ones
that we've lost and in memory
of everyone, our friends.
Mine is not quite done yet.
I have to go back and
finish it, but I love it.
And like I said, I am so
much inspired by this,
that I'm going to get another
one on my 83rd birthday.
(audience cheers)
- I love it.
It's so great.
My mom, actually, it was later in life,
I feel like she was in her sixties,
but she looked at my sister
and I one day and was like,
"I think I'm gonna get a tattoo."
And I was like, what?
And then we actually did the same thing.
My mom got a sun and I have the moon
and my sister's the star.
And our moon and star in her sun.
So like we got a tattoo together.
My family did something
similar, so I love this story.
I thought it was so cool.
Anyway, Judy, thank you so much.
I think it's so cool that
you're getting tattoos.
- Thank you.
- And it's even cooler
than it's with your family
and I'm liking your post right now.
And Judy, that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of The Kelly Clarkson Show,
they want to honor ultimate
achievers, just like you.
So they'll be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah!
You can get so many tattoos
with $1,000 is all I'm saying.